as a small
side as you're talking about the biology
let me comment that i spent
this is what i do this is what i do with
my life this is why i will never
accomplish anything as i spent
much of the morning trying to calc
trying to
do research on how many computations the
brain performs and how many um
how much energy it uses versus the
state-of-the-art cpus and gpus
now arriving at uh about 20 quadrillion
so that's 2 to the 10 to the 16
computation so
synaptic firings per second that the
brain does
and that's about a million times faster
than the uh
the let's say the 20 thread
state-of-the-arts
intel cpu the uh
the 10th generation and then their
similar calculation for the
for the uh for the gpu and all ended up
also trying to compute that it takes
10 watts to run the brain about and then
what does that mean in terms of calories
per day kilocalories
that's about 250 for an average
human brain that's 250 to 300
calories a day and uh so it ended up
being
a calculation where you're doing about
20 quadrillion calculations
uh that that are fueled by something
like depending on your diet
three bananas so three bananas results
in uh in a computation that's about a
million times
more powerful than the current stadia
computers
now let's take that one step further
there's some assumptions built in there
the assumption is that one what the
brain is doing is
just computation two the the
relevant computations are synaptic
firings and that there's nothing other
than synaptic firings that we have to
to factor so um
i'm forgetting his name right now
there's a very uh uh
famous neuroscientist at stanford just
passed away recently
who did a lot of the pioneering work on
glial cells
and showed that um his assessment glial
cells did a huge amount of the thinking
not just neurons and it opened up this
entirely different field of like what
the brain is and what consciousness is
you look at demacio's work on embodied
cognition and how much of what
we would consider consciousness or
feeling is happening outside of the
nervous system completely
happening in endocrine process involving
lots of other cells and signal
communication
you talk to somebody like penrose who
you've had on the show and even though
the penrose hammerhoff
conjecture is probably not right is
there something like that that might be
the case where we're actually having to
look at stuff happening at the level of
quantum computation of microtubules
i'm not arguing for any of those i'm
arguing that
we don't know how big the unknown
unknown set is
well at the very least this is this has
become like an infomercial for the human
brain
at the very but wait there's more
at the very least the three bananas buys
you a million times that's the very last
the very
impressive and then you could have uh
and then the synaptic firings we're
referring to is strictly the electrical
signals
that could be the mechanical
transmission of information like this
chemical transmission of information
there's
there's all kinds of other stuff going
on and then there's memory that's built
in that's also all tied in
not to mention which i'm learning more
and more about
it's not just about the uh the neurons
it's also about the immune system
that's somehow helping with the
computation so the entirety
and the entire body is helping with the
computation so the three bananas
it could buy you a lot it could buy you
a lot
you